hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I am about to go to a death world a
world of pain a world of destruction a
world of ravenous monsters that want to
tear me limb from limb and I'm gonna
play factorio to do that if you don't
know what factorio is it's a game where
you can build a factory of your dreams
where everything is happy where
everything is fun this is not going to
be fun this is not going to be happy if
you've ever played factorio before
you've probably played it on the default
map which looks bit like this that's
nice
all the red dots are enemies I'm not
gonna be playing like this I'm going to
be playing on a death world looks like
this every red dot there is an enemy
base it's not even an enemy that's an
enemy base I will be starting in the
center of that and that little sphere
that's a little open to be perfectly
honest I'm probably going to die many
times over I don't even know if this
possible is the thing I don't know I'm
not an expert at factorial I'm not even
good I don't even think I would consider
myself to be decent at factorial I think
I am barely able to hold myself together
in a factory I've never beaten the game
I've never launched a ship but I want to
try this because I'm clinically insane
if you don't know what you're about to
see buckle up because this is going to
be a mad dash this is going to be a
sprint unlike any other I do not know if
I'm going to make it the only caveat is
I've given myself richer resources to
start with and I've done that because I
think it's fair because getting the new
resource is going to take clearing out
nests of enemies the size and scope I've
never encountered so let's get into it
now if you don't know about factorial
it's a lovely game it's a game where you
just play around you build this like
Legos like Legos
you build you build and it's nice I know
a few techniques for building in the
game but I do not know a lot and frankly
my ability with like constructing
intricate faces that all fit together is
going to be severely compromised its I'm
just getting some wood to start up here
the important thing when you're getting
going is to understand how pollution
works especially when you've got about a
bazillion lighters breathing down your
neck they're drawn to pollution and your
factory creates a lot of pollution
especially once it gets going please
don't get me I just bought this rock hmm
[Laughter]
that's fine I'm going to be fine cuz I'm
not making any pollution yet I just want
to get enough wood to get started so
that when I do start making pollution I
don't die immediately that's the
objective here not to die immediately
like a big baby I'm just gonna I'm
preemptively getting a lot of wood
because I'm gonna need fuel at first and
I'm gonna have to use wood as that fuel
I think if I can get my foot in the door
and start making turrets and walls early
enough I should be okay if I can kind of
centralized my base get everything kind
of packed in together and just start
actually getting construction going
I need automation do it but if I can
just get it going enough I should be
okay yeah may not seem like it but I got
big brain up in this big head of mine
and this big branch got some big ideas
big ambitions you know it's got some
healthy ideas I'm gonna show the world
what I can do okay as soon as I lay down
the very first thing they start coming
for me so I'm gonna save call this death
one and boom
okay so it always starts with iron you
want to get the iron going so that you
can get iron
let's get that there get that there and
then boom it's the game's on baby games
on so that's gonna get that I can make
one more burner with that I'm just gonna
preemptively make these okay and then
one more burner get that going fill that
up and then we're off to the racist baby
we're off to the races we're off to the
races baby I need nine to make a new
grinder here we go there we go I think
they call it a not a grinder they call
it up to my name drill that's close
close that was close to correct let's
make one more of these it really is a
struggle of just getting this shootie
going come on hurry up yeah I'm messing
up all over the place alright another
one of these okay so the little trick
that you can do with these you can have
a coal insert into another coal and then
they feed each other : then they hold
onto the coal that they feed each other
and that way they can just constantly
feed feed pull does that make sense it
did not I bet I bet it did not let's see
you can just go and grab the call from
there you see what I mean you see you
said one you're picking up what I'm
putting down I think you are oh yeah
we're starting to go now okay it really
is like exponential like once you get
going it's just like go and then you go
it's a good app description break
commentary me thanks me okay now this is
where the existential panic is starting
to set in because if I don't hurry up
now I'm never going to never gonna be
able to do anything so I gotta you know
really start cranking and yanking
because if I don't crank and I don't
yank quick them spiders is gonna get me
it's a pollution look like okay the red
is the pollution so as soon as the red
starts touching those things I die okay
fine I don't have guns I die that's the
way it goes so I need as much iron
early as possible because I like
everything's iron base everything if you
don't have iron you've got nothing so I
need to get a higher
I need to get stone said I can see
number one one I'm doing and number two
I can little bit and then I can glue it
then I can believe so I did that because
I wanted to be able to do that and then
I wanted to do the thing with the thing
and that way I could do the thing
because the important thing for me is to
do the thing that I was gonna think that
the thing that I was gonna do is what I
was gonna do - the thing I don't have
enough Co I'm getting behind already oh
I need copper soon take some of this
come in one of these and take some cool
alright ah yeah that's what I like to
see that's the good stuff
alright I'm gonna make another one of
these a blink blink blink and yeah
that's how you do it
and say you do a baby okay make more of
these okay
this is good because it's like once I
start getting things going it's really
just a matter of time and literally time
is the only mitigating factor okay then
the next thing I do the next thing I
need to do is I need to start making
okay I need to start making I need to
start making why don't I have any
furnaces I got behind on furnaces
because I was too ambitious and we're
cool I always always need more it's like
never enough if you're playing as fast
as you should be playing it's like never
enough it's never enough
you always need just a little more okay
now that I got that going I'm going to
need to start building one of these one
of these one of these and then ten of
these after that I'll start worrying
about getting belts and stuff like that
and insert ores and then I need to get
science lab and then I need to build
science and then I put my right foot in
then I take my right foot out and then I
I do the hokey-pokey and I shake it all
about you get what I'm saying you get
it's a complicated dance it is a very
complicated dance and it takes someone
of unique hutzpah to be able to dance
the dance as well as someone like me is
able to do the dance okay so what am i
started doing now is I need to get water
but in order to get water I need to pump
water so I need to
huh huh bit really far away really far
away I wish I wasn't so far away okay
and then I guess that'll do you know I
guess it's that no it won't do that's
the thing it won't do it's gonna make
five of those screwed I I don't want air
everything to be far away how am i doing
unpolluted oh god I'm so behind how did
I survive I thought it was a head I'm
not a head I am behind oh god oh god oh
god oh god how did that happen how did
that happen how did that happen oh my
god I don't I don't even have enough
freaking frack I don't have enough RAC
is the thing I don't have enough RAC I
thought I had frak turns out I don't I
still don't have enough use okay I don't
need that many of those I need to these
but I'll hold off on one of them from
now because I need some more of these
and then one of these why is it or not
a furnace over there god what am i doing
this is not good this is not enough it
may seem like I'm doing a lot or two you
guys who have played a lot of this game
it may not seem like I'm doing anything
at all it may seem like I'm just being a
big old bill weed and I'm not going
anywhere
and if some of you are like wondering
why I'm panicking so much because you've
never seen this game before you have no
idea you have no goddamn idea what is
about to come down on my head in like
two seconds if I don't get research I
need to get research up then do turrets
then I got to start making bullets and
then then I might have a shot I might
have a shot is the thing I don't have
any science what am I even doing I can't
make any of that out of a science
oh my god I'm so incredible oh I just
cannot believe how boned I am oh yeah oh
yeah I'm not even gonna get the first
turret up by the time they start coming
down my way almost done with the turret
research I've got two of these things
now which is good twice as fast that's
good and boom okay let's make it a
turret and then next up will be
automation because I need to start
automating turrets because I literally
won't be able to make enough
wait you need this I was sitting there
doing nothing
thumb up but and that helps nobody if
I'm more of those how am i doing
no they're gonna sir come oh they're
gonna start coming no how did it end up
like this how did it end up like this I
thought I had time oh god okay so what
I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna you know
this is what I got I got one I got one
turret I've got one and that's fine
that's good enough I don't have
automation but I got one and I'm gonna
run out of freaking science here that
might carry it to automation
okay there's automation okay if they
start coming in the next two seconds I
am doomed okay so we got two of these I
need to put these by where there's gonna
be power [ __ ] slow I'm slow I'm slow
slow slow slow slow I'm so okay you're
making that you're making that you've
got that and that oh you need gears I
forgot you need gears oh yeah yeah okay
um you need coal not that much I really
don't know where they're gonna come from
first so I'm just gonna assume that
they're coming from the north first cuz
that would make logical sense to me okay
so you need another one of these that's
gonna feed beers into you
you're making gears and you've got that
and you put it in there and you take
this wood
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god make it make a
goddamn turret make it make a goddamn
turret and make it quick oh my god give
me oh my god make a turret oh my god
make a turret please dear Lord above
makeup dirt oh my god I'm gonna die I'm
gonna die this is how this is Oh die
this is how a die this is how a die this
is death this is how death happens
because I had the hubris to believe that
I could survive the truth is clearly I
cannot okay what do you need what do you
need you need this and this and you need
for the gears in there and then I need
to bring you to put this and then I can
use this as a unified chest for that and
you don't have coal this stupid burner
and why is it's a burner insert or why
isn't it a goddamn power inserter I
don't know but shut up having it time to
make it I mean those three that's good
threes good I like three that's like if
I need more bullets I need a lot more
bullets okay we've got a good number of
turrets down just not what I would like
especially up north we're actually
running pretty low yeah it really is
just the bullets that I'm concerned
about let's make some of these for now
this will be okay not enough I I forgot
I need direct insert for iron there I
don't know why I built it like that
there's a better way to build things
like that but you know in the panic I
really didn't have tons of time focus
oh no no no no get to my turrets oh my
god that's my goddamn turn down oh the
one place on the One Direction I didn't
freaking defend damn you damn you to
hell
god damn you Oh God there was resources
in there oh my god both of my bullet
manufacturer II really really you
freaking [ __ ] oh my god Oh Oh God
that is not what I needed that is not
what I needed that is not what I needed
Frick Frick look at pause okay that's
what I get for not defending my freaking
your bullet you're gonna what no no oh
my
well that was awful I know there was
probably some things I could do to
improve the speed but Mike I should have
been getting turrets up sooner and I
should add a better system for getting
bullets made but oh I shouldn't have
even bothered with anything besides the
gear manufacturer and frankly I probably
should have just made gears myself but
oh my god okay so what I'm gonna do
imma try that again but this time I'm
gonna give myself more space I doubled
the starting area which should in theory
give me more time that's the difference
pollution spreads at a certain rate if I
can get a bigger starting area I can get
more time all right take two here we go
oh baby yeah now you know what I
I've never tried this I was testing out
a few things but I've never actually
tried this what I'm doing right now so I
have no idea if it's even remotely
possible I really don't know how would I
know
I wouldn't know is the thing I just
would not know but let's try this with
two hundred percent starting area it was
a hundred percent before so two hundred
should give me a good amount of space to
do what I need to do my hand hurts from
pressing buttons so fast my lightning
speed claws like it's just so intense
that BPM that I'm pressing these buttons
I can't believe it's just the sheer
speed of my thingies it's blowing me
away and how good I am at the pressing
of buttons it's stunning even how
excellently I'm slamming down these flim
flam's
I got no commentary so I'm filling up
the air with random polluting hoping no
one's gonna notice that I actually don't
know what I'm talking about hope no one
does that would be unfortunate oh well
here I go again okay now we have this
going we're starting to climb back up
again III took a little more time to
make a little more infrastructure just
because I am a madman and I felt like I
should but this will hopefully give me a
little more leg up once I actually do
build the things that I do need and then
I'll cuz I got a little more time to
kill well I don't have any time to kill
but I've got a little more time to
prepare for the inevitable doom that is
about to befall me how's my pollution
doing not too shabby pretty dense in the
middle but I am working pretty hard my
machines pretty good I'll build belts
later everyone's probably yelling at me
like time to build a freakin power I got
a go all right cool so now I got this
get plenty of these so let's slang this
up this way now that the real trick is
gonna be I need to get walls that's
gonna be the the trickiest part of all
this I do need to get walls cuz if I
don't have walls I'm not gonna be able
to do anything I'm not gonna be able to
do what I need to do let's do automation
first this time it's no idle again not a
big base not get out of my face I don't
have a big base oh it's my call it's my
coal isn't it it's all the coal I dug
too greedy too greedily into the earth
there's my second science lab that up
there cool yeah that'll be good for now
come on automates done turd snacks then
walls and then speaking of walls as soon
as those burners going up I must start
making bricks and then I must start
making walls okay
Automation you're there
you're gonna make dirt I don't have
turrets you're gonna make bullets you're
gonna make bullets my friend I'm so
close to dirt okay you're gonna make
gears you're gonna feed into this dude
which is gonna make other things than
gears do the thing you're gonna make
turrets you're gonna make beers you're
gonna make more bullets another one of
these shirts is now done got a turret
not yet but we'll be not forget about
this I I'm still in the manual loading
stage which is not ideal but it's okay
let's start making bricks I know this is
very ramshackle I'm aware of that at the
same time I just I cannot even think
about anything else
at this juncture okay I got turrets okay
so they came from over here was it am I
crazy did they come from over here first
I literally cannot remember oh well I
get three down that's all that matters
oh no they came from South that's right
they came from South and ruined my day
okay I don't know if they will this time
I really don't know and frankly it
scares me that I don't know I need walls
that's my next research I don't have
science okay I'm gonna let that science
cook and I'm just gonna go get the stuff
that I need to get hey guys I just I
okay put three over here threes not the
ideal and frankly not having walls makes
me scared let's just start with one over
here one of these days I'll get walls
and have the brick soon to build walls
but not just now there we go
if I can get walls and how walls are
very expensive I forgot I was expensive
walls were great okay you know what I
don't need science science is for nerds
and I ain't no nerd okay Walt I'm kinda
give the first thing I'm gonna do is I'm
just gonna pocket up my turrets I think
that's the best I could hope for cuz I
can't wall up the whole base right away
definitely not but I can I can do a lot
to kind of alleviate some of the strain
of an attack because individual turrets
they they have a good amount of health
but they don't have a lot of health but
if you can get walls around them a
little bit better cuz cuz then the
biters will be attracted to them and if
they're the first thing the biters see
then they're gonna like try to get to
them
I think getting a lot of turrets is good
I probably should lay these down but I
just don't have the ammo for it at the
moment let me get these going and I need
more walls I need way way more walls
maybe I should do two burners per
furnace I'm not 100% sure how much brick
perd minor is needed let's get this guy
making walls you live for the walls my
friend that's your entire existence my
dude how am i doing oh that looks bad
that looks bad that looks very bad I
want walls please don't want walls so
badly never wanted anything more in my
life nothing more than just yeah nice
walls walls walls
save save save yeah okay that's not
right okay
I don't know if that's gonna be anywhere
near enough because it's still only
three turrets per those and as far as I
know that's not gonna be enough as far
as what I suspect anyway I really don't
actually know all right so my four
corner turrets are walled up so I need
to reinforce them with I guess I'm gonna
start
with just one just one extra turret in
the pocket fur now and then I'll worry
about trying to get them more later I
know this is not efficient
I am so painfully aware I probably
should have transitioned to doing belts
and sequences by you know I'm just a
little nervous I've had oh when did you
shoot things when did that happen I
would like to know when that happened
there's only three of them ah doesn't
seem right
okay so right now my four corners are
protected oh my god this is good this is
what we want this what we want I'm gonna
need a lot more all than that but we can
only get there through hard work and
commitment okay so what I need to do now
is I need to start there they are there
they are they're there yes yes yes yes
yes what I should do is I should double
layer them I should double layer them
cuz really like if they've they're gonna
come for those then I think I should
double layer them let me actually take
these down a bit like that makes sense
does that make sense everybody with me
okay cool I know they're attacking from
up north so I probably should focus on
that but you know what actually I will
do exactly that
I need logistics I think I need
logistics because if I'm gonna replan my
base I am going to need logistics oh
they were fighting up there okay fine
eventually I know I'm kind of like
cutting myself off from a lot of this
copper a copper not too important in the
very beginning it's very important later
but when it comes down to just building
walls and keeping things relatively not
exploded I feel like it's lower on the
totem pole
of priority anymore more wall please
more wall please
that's then what do they do wrong what
did i do differently here I did
something there to know whatever has
fine it's not a big deal not the
priority right now twelve seconds later
I know this is not important to fix but
it bugs me so I'm going to fix it that
was way too cheerful for how stressed I
am don't be doing the plant that that
when I don't need no plant that then I
need security I need to hear the Cape is
enclosed that's what I need to hear
everybody remember that what that's from
anybody know what I'm talking about no
no no okay cool just me hey hey hey hey
hey baby hey they're just gonna keep
coming which is the unfortunate thing
but the fact that I repelled that hey
hey hey that's pretty decent okay I
might actually make this I can't believe
I'm saying it but I might just maybe not
die a horrible painful death but I gotta
keep going I get along ok you know what
I just got a double-layer this last one
right here
is that right that seems right okay oh
my god I can't believe it
I think I made it I think I got the
foothold in I need to be able to survive
all I gotta do now is reconfigure my
base inside without destroying
everything that's the hard part I gotta
just redo it so that I can expand
exponentially but for right now that's a
foothold this is I got my four corners I
didn't put him exactly where I wish they
would have been but to be honest if it's
fine fair and fine totally fine totally
fair I've never been more stressed in my
life I'm sweating like crazy but there
is uh this is cool death awaits me on
this planet death unlike any other death
I've ever faced in my life
but I will rise to the challenge next
step is reconfiguring my base for more
efficiency because I can't keep running
back and forth like this I think it
served me well in the beginning but if I
keep running back and forth like that
I'm just gonna end up losing efficiency
when belts in automation like I don't
have to keep doing this I could make
more gun automation stuff I've got a lot
of resources here that I'm not doing so
I can just gotta get that done so thank
you everybody so much for watching if
you want to see more of this let me know
down the comments below I know there's a
little different from what I usually do
but I like to challenge and I like the
looming sense of impending doom it's
hard going it's a fun game too if you
haven't played factorio my god it's so
much fun it's so much fun just to build
things and this just adds like such a
level of stress beyond it but we'll see
how long I last cuz later on in the game
if anything gets through I think I would
be completely boned I just think there
would be no way that I could recover but
for now doing okay thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I'll
see you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]